This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是数字“2”%。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都算不上真正安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey guys, it's Gemma. First, I just want to take a moment to say how grateful I am to eat. each and every one of you who tune into the psychology of your 20s.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。嘿，大家好，我是杰玛。首先，我想花一点时间表达我对你们每一个收听《The Psychology of Your 20s》的听众的感激之情。
This show is honestly such a special space and knowing that so many of you are listening and reflecting and growing alongside me, it really does truly mean the world. I have so many instances of people DMing me and reaching out saying, you dropped that episode right when I needed to hear it. And I think it's because we're all so tuned into each other and so aligned in so many life experiences, which is just incredible and such a deep pride of my life that I've created a space for all of us can come together. A couple of months ago, a few of you already know this, I launched a brand new show called Mantra and I honestly feel like it is the perfect
这个节目老实说是一个非常特殊的空间，知道你们有这么多人一直在收听、反思并与我一起成长，这对我来说真的意义重大。我有很多次收到私信和联系，人们说：“你发布那一集正合我意，那正是我当时需要听到的。”我想这是因为我们都对彼此有着高度的共鸣，并且在许多人生经历中如此契合，这简直太不可思议了，也是我一生中深感自豪的一件事，我创造了一个能让我们所有人聚集在一起的空间。几个月前，你们中的一些人已经知道了，我推出了一档全新的节目，叫做《Mantra》，我真心觉得它是
companion to the psychology of your 20s. Each week I introduce a new empowering phrase, one simple but powerful mantra. And then I unpack its meaning, both what it means to me personally, how I've maybe struggled with it, how I've tried to implement it, and also what it means on a collective conscious level. This show is really deeply personal to me. It's where all the vulnerable conversations are taking place. And if you haven't had a chance to check it out yet, I'd love to invite you to listen. I also just started releasing monthly bonus episodes for Matra on Open Mind Plus.
《The Psychology of Your 20s》的完美伴侣。每周我会介绍一个新的赋能短语，一个简单但强大的咒语/座右铭。然后我会剖析它的含义，既包括它对我的个人意义、我可能如何与它挣扎过、我如何尝试去践行它，也包括它在集体意识层面的意义。这个节目对我来说非常私人。这是所有走心对话发生的地方。如果你还没有机会收听，我很想邀请你来听听。我也刚刚开始在Open Mind Plus上为《Mantra》发布每月的独家加更节目。
where I answer some questions and DMs that come through to mantra open mind on Instagram. So if there's something you've been dying to ask me that I haven't done an episode on, I may just answer your question over there. I have so much in store for this season of mantra, and I hope you'll join me over there if you haven't already. I also wanted to share a clip from one of my favorite episodes so far. I trust myself to make the best decisions with what I know now. check it out. Okay, reformer Pilates aside. Let's get into it. It's time for this week's mantra. I trust
在那里我回答一些发到Instagram上 mantra open mind 的问题和私信。所以如果你有什么非常想问我而我还没有做成节目的问题，我可能就会在那里回答你的问题。我为这一季的《Mantra》准备了非常多的内容，如果你还没加入的话，我希望你能加入我们。我还想分享我目前最喜欢的节目之一的一个片段。我相信自己能根据目前已知的信息做出最好的决定。来看看吧。好吧，普拉提核心床先放一边。我们切入正题。是时候公布本周的座右铭了。我相信
myself to make the best decision with what I know now. A big misconception or myth that we tend to believe as humans is that there is one best decision for us to make at every single turn. And if we are to carefully observe and analyze the environment, all the context, all the information that we have, we will be able to discern what that decision is, and it's that decision that will unlock our dream life. To take that kind of further, that means that there is this perfect path through life, almost, and we can obtain that perfect path by making the correct choice at every single point where we need to make a choice. Do you kind of see the impossibility of that? Because that's really what it is. It's impossible, it's improbable. Making the most perfect decision is not actually something
自己能根据目前已知的信息做出最好的决定。作为人类，我们倾向于相信的一个巨大误区或神话是，在我们面临的每一个转折点上，都有一个对我们来说最好的决定。如果我们仔细观察和分析环境、所有的背景以及我们拥有的所有信息，我们就能够辨认出那个决定是什么，而正是那个决定将开启我们的梦想生活。更进一步说，这意味着人生几乎存在一条完美的道路，我们可以通过在每一个需要做出选择的节点做出正确选择来获得那条完美道路。你看出其中的不可能了吗？因为事实确实如此。这是不可能的，也是不大可能的。做出最完美的决定其实并不是
that we can always do because we don't always have the information that hindsight kind of provides. What we tend to forget is that there really is never a perfect choice. Otherwise, it wouldn't be a decision, right? Like the word decision means to resolve some kind of competition between two juxtaposed and perhaps equally good outcomes or options or equally bad outcomes and options. I'd like to think about it this way. If you had to choose between two choices on a menu, and one choice is your favorite meal ever, and you know it's cooked deliciously, and it's only $10. And the other dish is a food that you're allergic to, surrounded by other foods you don't like, and it's out of your budget. The choice is actually quite easy,
我们总是能做到的，因为我们并不总是拥有事后诸葛亮那种视角所提供的信息。我们往往忘记了，世上其实从来没有完美的抉择。否则，它就不会被称为决定了，对吧？“决定”这个词的意思是解决某种竞争，即在两个并列的、或许同样好的结果或选项之间，或者同样坏的结果和选项之间做出裁决。我喜欢这样思考。如果你必须在菜单上的两个选项中做出选择，一个选项是你最喜欢的美食，你知道它烹饪得极其美味，而且只要10美元。而另一道菜是你过敏的食物，周围环绕着其他你讨厌的食物，并且超出了你的预算。这个选择其实相当简单，
so it's not really a decision, right? A decision only emerges when we feel torn by two alternative outcomes that have very similar pros and cons. And the reason we feel stuck in those moments is that we don't want to regret not choosing the right one. What we're battling is perfectionism. Of course, it is perfectionism. You probably already guessed that. But it's also our desire, maybe even our need to be in control and to have some assurance that it's all going to turn out okay, which is quite honestly something that no one can really give us, you're just going to have to see for yourself. And that's scary, but it's also really exciting when you think about it, because if you knew the outcome of every single decision that you were ever going to make
所以这其实算不上一个决定，对吧？只有当我们被两个优缺点非常相似的替代结果纠缠时，决定才会出现。我们在那些时刻感到卡住的原因是，我们不想后悔没有选择正确的那一个。我们在与完美主义作斗争。当然，这就是完美主义。你可能已经猜到了。但这也是我们的渴望，甚至可能是我们对掌控感的需要，以及对事情最终都会好起来的某种保证的需要——老实说，这是任何人都无法真正给予我们的，你只能自己去亲眼见证。这很可怕，但仔细想想，它也真的很让人兴奋，因为如果你知道你将要做的每一个决定的结果
from now until the day you died, what's the point of living your life? Genuinely, what is the actual point of waking up and going forward without a little bit of excitement and a little bit of surprise. But sometimes the possibility and grappling with the what-ifs and the alternative hypotheticals, it's a scary, you know, mental environment to be in. And so we don't see it in the same way that I was just describing it. We don't see it as exciting. And in our desire to make the perfect choice, we do end up sacrificing a few things, peace being one of them, action being the other. This specific kind of an action that I'm talking about, it has its own name. you've probably heard of it. It's called decision paralysis or choice overload. And it explains what
从现在直到你死去的那一天，那活着还有什么意义呢？说实话，如果没有一点兴奋感和一点惊喜，醒来并继续前进到底还有什么真正的意义。但有时，这种可能性以及与“如果当初”和各种假设的纠缠，是一个可怕的、你知道的心理环境。所以我们并没有像我刚才描述的那样来看待它。我们不认为它是令人兴奋的。在渴望做出完美选择的过程中，我们最终确实牺牲了一些东西，平静是其中之一，行动是另一个。我所说的这种特定行动不能，它有它自己的名字。你可能听说过。它被称为决定瘫痪或选择过载。它解释了
happens to our brain when we feel overwhelmed by all the possibilities and all of the potential what ifs. What if it turned out this way? But what if it turned out that way? Kind of see where I'm going with that. We would think, naturally, that having more options would make us feel more free and more liberated. It seems that it actually does the opposite. I want to talk about one of my favorite studies ever of all time, and it's a study that was done on regret. Regret is really at the heart of this whole question of how do I trust myself when I don't have full information? Because what we're really worried about is, what if I make a decision and I regret it? So this study was published almost two decades ago, but the findings still ring so very true. Basically, what this study
当我们被所有的可能性和所有潜在的“如果”压得喘不过气来时，我们的脑子里究竟发生了什么。如果结果是这样呢？但如果结果是那样呢？大概能明白我的意思吧。我们自然会认为，拥有更多的选项会让我们感到更加自由和解放。但事实似乎恰恰相反。我想谈谈我有史以来最喜欢的研究之一，这是一项关于后悔的研究。后悔其实正是“在我没有全部信息时，我该如何相信自己”这一整个核心问题的关键所在，因为我们真正担心的是：万一我做了决定又后悔了呢？所以这项研究发表于近二十年前，但研究结果至今依然振聋发聩。基本上，这项研究
found is that you are more likely to regret inaction than action. Time and time again, across this research project, these researchers found that those who they spoke to who had the most regret in life, it didn't come from one decision. It was not a singular decision or even multiple wrong decisions that heightened their regret. It was regret from times when they had stayed stagnant because they were too scared to make a choice. They had stayed in the same place to avoid discomfort, stayed in the same job, stayed in the same relationship that they knew wasn't right for them, the same city where there were bad people, where there weren't opportunities, where they felt lonely. And eventually, they came to resent their past self, not for a choice,
发现的是：比起行动，你更有可能对不作为感到后悔。在这个研究项目中，这些研究人员一次又一次地发现，那些在生活中感到最后悔的人，并非源于某一个决定。并不是某一个决定、甚至不是多个错误的决定加剧了他们的后悔。而是因为他们太害怕做出选择而原地踏步时的后悔。他们为了逃避不适感而停留在原地，呆在同一份工作里，呆在明知不适合自己的同一段关系里，呆在那个有坏人、没有机会、让他们感到孤独的同一个城市里。最终，他们开始怨恨过去的自己，不是因为做出了某个选择，
but for a lack of choice, for a lack of decision-making. This is what the misplaced desire for perfection in all decisions costs us. It ends up costing us our happiness. So this is the first takeaway of the day. are stuck between doing and not doing something, always choose to do it. And with that, I want you to know that choosing to live in perfectly, choosing to make a choice, even if you're not sure if it's the right one, it's actually going to give you so many more experiences, so many more options to learn than you would obtain from just trying really hard to make one right choice. The second thing to note when we talk about making the best decision is that as humans, research has shown that we are pretty bad at predicting what is going to make us happy or unhappy about the future due to something
而是因为缺乏选择，缺乏决策力。这就是对所有决定追求完美的错位渴望所付出的代价。它最终牺牲了我们的幸福。所以这是今天的第一个核心收获。当你卡在做某事和不做某事之间时，永远选择去做。伴随着这一点，我想让你知道：选择不完美地生活，选择做出一个选择，即使你不确定它是否正确，实际上会给你带来更多的经历、更多的学习选项，这远比你拼命试图做出一个正确选择所能获得的要多得多。在谈到做出最佳决定时，需要注意的第二件事是，作为人类，研究表明我们在预测未来什么会让我们快乐或不快乐这方面其实相当糟糕，这由于一种
called effective forecasting, where we tend to think about our emotions as being more heightened or stronger in the future. So either we're going to be so much happier, incredibly happy if everything works out the way we wanted to, or we're going to be truly devastated if we're they don't. So really what we are, what we are stuck between, is two extremes, and that means that the stakes feel especially heightened. What actually happens, though, when we make a decision, when we get to our future, regardless of what the outcome was, we actually tend to return to a pretty stable emotional state fairly quickly after good or bad things happen. So a study from Deakin University here in Australia, found that actually we overestimate the intensity and the duration of how long
被称为情感预测的现象，在这种现象中，我们往往认为未来自己的情绪会更加高涨或更强烈。所以要么我们会变得无比快乐，如果一切都如我们所愿地发展的话就会极其快乐；要么如果事情不如意，我们会真的感到崩溃。所以实际上，我们所处的、被困在其中的是两个极端，这意味着利害关系感觉特别重大。然而，实际发生的情况是，当我们做出决定，来到未来时，无论结果如何，在好事或坏事发生后不久，我们实际上往往会相当快地恢复到相当稳定的情绪状态。因此，澳大利亚迪肯大学的一项研究发现，实际上我们高估了我们的幸福感会持续的
our happiness, but also how long our misery is going to last. What we are really good at, though, is being resilient and adapting to our circumstances. We are highly adaptable creatures, so even if you may think that it's the wrong decision, most of the time, you can still progress and find a way out. It's also not like once you've made a decision, you are locked into that decision for life. You can change your mind. You are allowed to change your mind. Also, I always pose this hypothetical to people who have found themselves regretting past actions or past choices. I get so many messages from people saying, I'm so upset at myself for doing this. I feel like I've completely ruined my life. I feel like I can link everything back to that time five years ago.
强度和持续时间，同样也高估了我们的痛苦会持续多久。不过，我们真正擅长的是保持弹性和适应环境。我们是高度适应性强的生物，所以即使你可能认为这是一个错误的决定，大多数时候，你仍然可以继续前进并找到出路。而且，这也不是说一旦你做了决定，你就一辈子被锁死在这个决定上了。你可以改变心意。你被允许改变心意。另外，我总是把这个假设抛给那些发现自己对过去的行动或过去的选择感到后悔的人。我收到很多人发来的消息说：“我对自己的所作所为感到很难过。我觉得我彻底毁了我的生活。我觉得我可以把一切都追溯到五年前的那个时间点。”
How do you know that that choice didn't save you from an even worse fate? How do you know that this actually wasn't the better outcome? You can't, and the chances are you're coping with it better than what a previous version of you would have thought you could cope with. So, if we can't ever truly know what is going to make us happy or how things are going to work out, how do we still make the best decisions? Because it is important to still put some thought into it. Well, what it comes down to is self-trust. I love self-trust. It is one of my favorite concepts. But basically what it means is that you trust your ability. to interpret the information you have now, but you also trust your future self to handle
你怎么知道那个选择没有让你免于更糟糕的命运呢？你怎么知道这实际上不是一个更好的结果呢？你无法知道，而且很有可能你对现状的处理比过去版本的你所认为的要好得多。所以，如果我们永远无法真正知道什么会让我们快乐或事情会如何发展，我们该如何做出最好的决定呢？因为对事情进行一些思考仍然很重要。好吧，这归根结底在于自我信任。我喜欢自我信任。这是我最喜欢的概念之一。但它基本上意味着你相信自己的能力——
whatever comes their way. You are not so focused on trying to make grand predictions. Instead, you go forward with the information you have currently available to you, and you also go forward with an attitude of forgiveness and grace if it doesn't end up being what you want all along. You forgive yourself for not knowing, and with that you have greater acceptance for whatever is going to be. Each of us, I think, has a very ancient and deep intuition for what we know is right. You can kind of feel it in your body. You can feel it by where your thoughts keep returning to, by your emotions,
去解读你现在拥有的信息，但你也相信未来的自己能够应对迎面而来的任何事情。你不会过于专注于试图做出宏大的预测。相反，你带着目前手头可用的信息前进，并且如果它最终没有变成你一直想要的样子，你也带着宽恕和优雅的态度前进。你原谅自己当时的不了解，并随之对即将发生的一切抱有更大的接受度。我认为，我们每个人对什么是正确的都有着非常古老而深刻的直觉。你能在你的身体里感受到它。你可以通过你的思绪不断回归的方向、你的情绪来感受到它，
but we can become detached from that in modern society. So to get our way back to trust and trusting our intuition, I do think it's a process of trial and error, letting yourself be led by your gut instinct and just seeing whether it's try and self-correcting, going back and learning, okay, what reactions did I listen to that I maybe shouldn't have listened to? What reactions were happening to oppose those reactions that are actually maybe my gut instinct, if that makes sense? You want to also start asking, you know, can I trust the little voice in my head? Is that voice my intuition or is it my anxiety? When I listen to it and I
但在现代社会中，我们可能会与这种直觉脱节。所以要想找回信任并相信我们的直觉，我确实认为这是一个反复试验的过程，让自己被直觉引导，然后看看它是否需要尝试自我修正，回过头来去学习：“好吧，我听从了哪些其实或许不该听从的反应？有哪些与那些反应相对立的反应，其实可能才是我真正的直觉呢？”如果这说得通的话。你还想开始问自己：“我能相信脑海中的那个小声音吗？那个声音是我的直觉还是我的焦虑？当我倾听它并
follow its directive, do I end up happier or not? Self-trust is also built on resilience. and trying over, even when it didn't go right the first time, you know, if we were defined by one failure, one poor choice, one bad decision, and that was where you stayed, almost all of the world would still be where they were when they were teenagers, afraid to never try again. But we do. We face failure. We face bad decisions and we overcome them. And people go on to create, to see, to do amazing things, and they learn how to better judge
按照它的指示去做时，我最终变得更快乐了吗？还是没有？”自我信任也是建立在韧性之上的。即使第一次没有做好，也要不断重试，你知道的，如果我们被一次失败、一次糟糕的选择、一个错误的决定所定义，并且你就停留在那里，那么几乎整个世界都会停留在他们十几岁时的状态，害怕再也不去尝试。但我们没有。我们面对失败。我们面对糟糕的决定并战胜它们。人们继续创造、看到、做出惊人的事情，他们学会了如何更好地判断
what's right for them. and also trust that they'll be capable anyway, even if they fail. That is why I always say that the opposite of decision anxiety or anxiety in general, it's not calm, it's not peace, it's trust, knowing that whatever happens, you are going to be okay, you'll manage, you'll find your way through, you are going to make the most of your situation. We've already talked so much about embracing the wisdom we already hold, trusting our intuition, to letting go of the preference,
什么对他们是正确的，并且也相信自己无论如何都有能力做到，即使失败了。这就是为什么我总是说，决定焦虑或普遍焦虑的反义词不是冷静，不是平静，而是信任——知道无论发生什么，你都会好起来的，你会应付过来的，你会找到出路的，你会充分利用你的处境。我们已经讨论了那么多关于拥抱我们已经拥有的智慧、相信我们的直觉，以及放下
to make the perfect decision. This mantra is all about showing up with confidence, accepting that we are doing our best with what we know right now and knowing that growth comes from trusting the process as well as ourselves, even when the path feels uncertain. So coming up, let's get personal. I'm going to share some moments when trusting myself felt really, really difficult and the lessons I've learnt from leaning into uncertainty and how this mantra has shaped the way I make choices today. Stay tuned after this brief pause. Now that we've looked at the meaning behind today's mantra, it's time to get personal with you guys and share some of my own insights and reflections
做出完美决定的执念。这个座右铭的全部意义在于带着自信出现，接受我们正在用我们现在所知的一切做到最好，并知道成长来自于相信过程以及相信我们自己，即使道路感觉不确定。接下来，让我们谈谈个人感受。我将分享一些相信自己感觉非常非常困难的时刻，我从顺应不确定性中学到的教训，以及这个座右铭是如何塑造我今天做出选择的方式的。短暂暂停后，请继续收听。既然我们已经探讨了今天座右铭背后的含义，是时候和大家谈谈我自己的个人感受，分享一些我对这句话的见解和反思了。
about this phrase. I trust myself to make the best decision with what I know now. Thank you so much for listening to catch the rest of this episode and honestly so much more. Search for mantra wherever you get your podcasts. We'll also drop a link in the show notes of course. course and as always make sure to follow mantra to help others discover the show. Talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
我相信自己能根据目前已知的信息做出最好的决定。非常感谢大家的收听，想要收听本集节目的其余部分以及更多精彩内容，请在获取播客的任何地方搜索“Mantra”。当然，我们也会在节目文稿中附上链接。像往常一样，请务必关注“Mantra”以帮助其他人发现这个节目。回头见。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是数字“2”%。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important. important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有一个更重要
Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
对黑人来说重要的年份。请在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都算不上真正安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？这向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through.
但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这样做。请在AHA radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过
the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。